die oder sie ist zu einem solchen todes
fluss geworden tonnenweise treiben
fischkadaver in diesem fluss
fischsterben auf hunderten kilometern
bis jetzt hat niemand dafür eine
erklärung bild ist heute an diesem
todesfall
es nimmt kein ende jeden tag jede
sekunde sterben tausende fische und mit
ihnen das gesamte ökosystem der oder in
den sozialen medien scheint die frage
des verursachers der umweltkatastrophe
bereits beantwortet
diese weise flüssigkeit ist der grund
für das fischsterben abwasser der
polnischen papierfabrik jack das werk
steht in der stadt urlauber direkt am
ufer des grenzflusses doch woher kommt
dieser verdacht der aktivisten
die papierfabrik steht bereits seit
monaten in der kritik die oder mit ihren
abwässern zu verseuchen
märz diesen jahres aktivisten
unterbrechen die stadtratssitzungen olah
war die männer stellen den teilnehmern
flaschen auf den tisch gefüllt seien
diese mit kontaminiertem oder wasser
angeblich verseucht durch jack bruce
abwässer doch der präsident des
unternehmens streitet jegliche
verunreinigung in der oder ab er
behauptet das unternehmen produziere
ökologisch nachhaltig bei den
vermeintlich verunreinigten
flüssigkeiten handele es sich um
sauberes wasser
die polizei nun aber startete bereits
einen fahndungsaufruf
ermittler suchen zwei männer die am 27
juli auf einem boot auf der oder waffen
ermittler hoffen diese personen können
jetzt wichtige hinweise geben ob sie zum
telefon greifen das angebot ist
jedenfalls lukrativ
polnische behörden lobten bereits eine
belohnung in höhe von einer million
zloty aus also umgerechnet fast 215.000
euro
sorgt die oder katastrophe in
deutschland hauptsächlich für entsetzen
und sorge entwickelt sie sich auf der
anderen seite des grenzflusses immer
mehr zum politikum der polnische
premierminister entliess bereits die
chefs der umwelt und wasserbehörde
europaweit forschen währenddessen
fachleute an der ursache der
umweltkatastrophe auch eine
deutsch-polnische taskforce ermittelt
unser bild reporter sind jetzt am todes
plus klarer marie becker an der oder und
ibrahim calli schönen guten morgen durch
beide klarer mit dir mal angefangen du
stehst dort direkt an der oder
beschreibe uns diesen fluss ja diesen
todes fluss in diesen stunden
besteht hier in frankfurt und hier
wurden in den vergangenen tagen 3,2
tonnen toter fisch aus diesem wasser
geholt und immer noch weiß keiner warum
keiner kennt den genauen grund man kann
sich das vorstellen hier hingen in der
letzten in den letzten tagen ein
beißender gestank in der luft mehr als
3000 kilo toter fisch die hier an land
gespült wurden die hier in der sonne
liegen die hier verwesen das wirklich
gespenstische vorstellung gespenstische
bilder die wir auch gesehen haben und
auch hier obwohl die offizielle
information ist das wohl jetzt alle
kadaver aus dem wasser geholt wurden
weggebracht wurden jetzt in schwedt
verbrannt werden sollen sieht man immer
wieder im wasser kleinere tote fische
treiben und das ist wirklich ein
gruseliger anblick den man da hat denn
ich meine wasser ist ja normalerweise
auch so das element das die menschen
zusammenbringen dass die leute her zieht
und das ist wirklich in ja in diesem
moment ein todes fluss geworden
sozusagen die offizielle neue
information des oberbürgermeisters rené
wilke ja aus frankfurt war das jetzt
auch wieder neue lebende fischschwärme
hier im in der oder entdeckt wurden das
heißt man hofft darauf dass jetzt
sozusagen die die katastrophe die
umweltkatastrophe hier schon
nicht mehr so ex also dass er sozusagen
die umweltkatastrophe hier an andere
fragen und frankfurt vorbei gegangen ist
aber das ist natürlich keine entwarnung
denn man weiß immer noch nicht wie
gesagt was eigentlich die ursache war
und so lange die nicht feststeht weiß
man eben auch nicht kennt man nicht das
genaue ausmaß dieser katastrophe lasst
uns doch nach der todesursache all
dieser fische dieser tonnenweise fische
die dort verendet sind einmal suchen auf
einmal auf diese spurensuche gehen mit
übrigen cayet auf der polnischen seite
unterwegs an der oder das stinkt zum
himmel dass man nach mehr als einer
woche immer noch nicht weiß was die
ursache es wird dass vertuscht
er würde schon sagt dass wir stehen hier
in baden polizei auf der polnischen
seite und hier ist das gestern von der
polnischen regierung dass es in den
entnommenen wasserproben aus der oder
keine toxischen substanzen und in den
entnommenen fischproben also dass der
kadaver quasi keine pestizide gefunden
worden insgesamt hat die polnische
regierung aber jetzt drei theorien die
dieses mögliche fische sterben erklären
könnten die erste theorie lautet dass
hier einfach giftige stoffe illegal ins
wasser eingeleitet wurden bei
produktionsprozessen von den hier
ansässigen industriebetriebe die zweite
option könnte sein dass das hier einfach
alles auch irgendwie aus natürliche
ursache passiert ist das bedeutet ein
multi kausalzusammenhang aus erhöhten
schadstoffwerten denn durch proben die
zuvor entnommen wurden weiß man dass
hier ein hoher salzgehalt herrscht dann
hast du hier einen niedrigen wasserstand
rossi erhöhte temperaturen und dieser
kausalzusammenhang dieser multi
kausalzusammenhang dieser natürliche
zusammenhang könnte für dieses fische
sterben letztendlich die ursache sein
und die dritte option die lautet dass
hier einfach eventuell auch chlor
haltiges brauchwasser in die oder
geflossen ist die dieses mögliche fische
sterben erklärt
[Musik]